Vivien Gasque donc tête de tête de liste
PSO municipal à Montini le breteneux
désigné tête de liste il y a quelques
jours he par la section locale du du PS
votre implantation sur la ville est
pourtant assez récente vous n'êtes
arrivé qu'en 2011 vous étiez plutôt du
côté de saclou auparavant comment vous
êtes arrivé sur la ville de Montini tout
à fait B j'ai choisi de d'arrivé sur ce
territoire en 2011 je suis arrivé en
2012 en fait l'année l'année dernière
euh ben j'ai choisi territoire pour un
certain nombre de raisons
professionnel familial et puis c'est un
territoire comme on dit où il fait bon
vivre donc c toujours intéressant de
venir tester ces territoir là en fait je
le connais depuis un certain nombre
d'années puisque j'ai quelques amis qui
sont sur sur
Montini sur la sur la ville nouvelle
aussi à Guill encour donc voilà je ne le
découvrais pas et puis quand on fait des
études avec un petit peu d'urbanisme on
parle toujours un petit peu des villes
nouvell donc voilà pas une découverte
totale mais un réjouissement c'est
toujours toujours
c'est c'est une belle ville ouais vous
êtes chef vous êtes donc maintenant en
tête de cette opposition il y avait au
départ Sandrine grangom qui est
l'ancienne élu d'opposition elle est
devenue secrétaire fédéral responsable
dans le département du Parti socialiste
elle a démissionné de de ses fonctions
c'est son départ justement au cours de
mandat qui a un petit peu précipité les
choses aussi vous êtes rapproché d'elle
pour voir comment organiser l'opposition
maintenant que elle c'est sûr elle ne
sera pas candidate les choses se sont
passées dans un autre ordre elle a elle
a annoncé son départ à la section
socialiste de Montini euh peu de temps
après mon arrivée en réalité euh et donc
les choses ont commencé à s'organiser en
interne au parti socialiste et j'ai pris
ma part comme tous les militants de de
l'organisation de de la future campagne
et puis et puis on a on a souhaité
avancer par rapport au calendrier
national la la la désignation du
candidat parce que normalement c'était
plutôt pour le mois d'octobre voilà tout
à fait date nationale c'est ça voilà euh
donc on a jugé que dans la situation qui
était la nôtre avec le départ de
Sandrine Grandgambe nous aurions un
déficit de notoriété voilà à à combler
donc d'où l'idée de de commencer à
discuter avec les inimontins assez tôt
et puis de les écouter puisque
aujourd'hui c'est le c'est tout le sens
de notre démarche c'est de de se
présenter mais surtout d'écouter les
inimontins sur ce qu'ils ont à sur ce
qu'ils ont à dire sur leur ville alors
une fois de plus je vais juste insister
là-dessus mais ment la ville c'est un
secteur des divin que vous connaissez
puisque vous y travaillez là aussi
pourquoi ne pas être allé faire candidat
candidature acte de candidature sur
cette cette partie du département et
bien parce que je travaille en fait en
tant que fonctionnaire sur cette autre
partie du département et je je tiens à
faire la part des choses entre le mon
métier de fonctionnaire qui demande une
une relative indépendance du politique
et puis et puis la la politique mon
activité publique ici donc vous arrivz
sur une commune qui est plutôt ancrée au
centre à droite centre droit depuis 1977
l'arrivée de Nicolas Abou ensuite il a
passé la main à Michel logier c'est pas
forcément une commune très évidente pour
un
socialiste tout à fait alors dire que
c'est une commune de droite depuis 77 je
pense que c'est un petit peu
excessif Nicolas Abou n'est pas arrivé
avec une étiquette de
droite une centre centre gauche centre
centre droit oui et puis les choses ont
évolué
depuis je je ne crois pas que Montini
soit une ville de
droite et et je crois qu'il y a une
place pour la gauche pour la solidarité
pour la préservation de l'environnement
pour pour toutes ces valeurs qui nous
qui sont fondatrices pour nous ici à
Montini euh et puis les les résultats
des dernières élections régionales
nationales montrent que nous ne sommes
pas dans une ville de droite alors pour
vous c'est une ville sociologiquement à
gauche pour autant si on s'en tient
uniquement au scrutin municipal 2008 de
listes Michel logier 60,80 % des
suffrages exprimé face à la liste donc
menée à l'époque par Sandrine grandamb
élu au premier tour avec 60% 60,80 % une
assez belle avance euh pour pour
quelqu'un qui n'était euh finalement
maire que depuis 4 ans euh et comment
vous allez inverser la tendance en vous
basant uniquement sur les résultats des
élections régionales législatives ça va
être un petit peu
compliqu tout à fait une élection
municipale ne se gagne absolument pas
sur sur un score national de toute façon
non je crois qu'on va parler on va
parler de de bilan de d'une d'une d'une
équipe municipale sortante on va parler
aussi de
l'avenir et on va on va proposer quelque
chose pour l'avenir auximtin on va
essayer de même proposer du rêve
pourquoi pas puisque la ville nouvelle
c'est c'est construite là-dessus sur un
sur un idéal dans les années 60 70 DEP
80 euh nous on pense que qu'il y a il y
a un temps maintenant pour le renouveau
et que on peut repenser l'avenir de
notre notre ville nouvelle ici alors
2008 c'était on était encore sous
l'héritage de Nicolas Abou hein qui est
resté une trentaine d'années maire de
une petite trentaine d'années maire de
maire de Montini euh maintenant les gens
connaissent un petit peu mieux Michel
Michel logier euh voilà on aura
programme contre programme personnalité
contre personnalité aussi euh nous ce
que ce qu'on
notre notre préoccupation première c'est
l'écoute actuellement on est on est à
l'écoute designentin depuis euh depuis
quelques mois déjà euh on va les voir
dans des portes- à porte on les écoute
sur la réforme des rythmes scolaires
vendredi on a fait remplir des
questionnaires des à des parents
d'élèves à la sortie des écoles eu voilà
on on construit pour l'instant
patiemment nos propositions en écoutant
les imontins mais vous dites
personnalité contre personnalité
qu'est-ce qui vous différencie de Michel
logier justement alors je m'interdit de
parler de mon âge tout de suite
je vais peut-être incarner un petit peu
mieux que Michel logier le le
renouveau ce qu'on croit c'est que on a
on a la possibilité de de réfléchir
localement à des à des sur des sur des
propositions pragmatiques
concrètes je je pense qu'on a une
capacité alors je dis tout le temps on
quand vous me demandez moi
personnellement je vous réponds on parce
que ce qui fait notre force souvent à
gauche et en particulier à Montini ici
c'est le c'est le
collectif et et derrière moi il y a
plusieurs générations de de de
socialiste et puis de personnalités de
gauche depuis qui sont sur le sur le
bassin sur sur Montini depuis 77 78 80
qu' on était présent sur des listes
municipales dans les années 89 95 et et
puis on a aussi des jeunes issus du
Mouvement des Jeunes Socialistes par
exemple ou des jeunes adhérents ici qui
qui donnent un nouveau souffle à notre à
notre réflexion donc voilà derrière moi
tout un tout un collectif et je pense
que c'est la la la grosse différence
avec avec l'équipe actuelle c'est on a
un collectif inventif imaginatif euh
très à l'écoute de design Montin avec
vraiment l'envie de l'envie de bien
faire pour cette ville et et de penser
nouveau voilà simpement reconduire les
les dispositifs existants mais aussi
refaire quelque chose de neuflec mais
quand vous parlez de collectif est-ce
que ça veut dire que Europe Écologie Les
vert le Front de Gauche également sont
déjà derrière vous alors pour l'instant
pas encore estce qu'il y avait une
alliance en 200 une alliance en 2008 il
y a eu bien souvent des alliances avec
avec une gauche unie ici sur Montini euh
alliance alliance la dernière fois avec
une liste unique une liste uni à gauche
alors aujourd'hui c'est pas encore fait
euh bon on est en contact très régulier
euh avec nos nos amis d'EUR écologie les
verts ou du Parti de Gauche notre
intention notre souhait nous c'est de
pouvoir de pouvoir passer un accord avec
avec nos nos partenaires euh on pense
que ça a du sens d'avoir une liste de
gauche réuni sur sur Montini pour faire
des propositions qui regroupent toute la
gauche et quand je dis toute la gauche
il s'agit de la gauche mais il s'agit
aussi de tous ces gens qui sont pas
forcément dans une catégorie la gauche
ou la droite mais qui vont être à
l'écoute de de propositions euh voilà
vous pensez que tout le monde peut se
mettre d'accord que ce soit Europe
Écologie Les Verts le Front de Gauche
également qui s'est montré au niveau
national plutôt critique envers l'action
du gouvernement socialiste tout à fait
comme vous le voyez on arrive à se
mettre d'accord au gouvernement avec
Europe Écologie Les ver donc je pense
qu'on pouvoir y arriver le Front de
gauche on a quand même quelques racines
communes parce que finalement pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux c'est des
gens qui viennent du Parti socialiste
historiquement donc on a on a au moins
la même histoire euh donc aujourd'hui il
y a une certaine critique par rapport au
gouvernement ça s'est dégradé peut-être
ces derniers temps oui c'est sûr que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et François
Hollande pas forcément exactement la
même la même vision du pays bon ici on
parle de politique locale voilà on parle
pas de politique nationale et euh on
n'entend pas gagner ces électionsl euh
uniquement avec un bilan critique du
gouvernement ou uniquement avec un bilan
favorable à celui du gouvernementi tant
les accords dans tous les partis se font
tout de même aussi au niveau
départemental on regarde en gén
laissee sociiste en contre laete
Dee une are commune si par exemple le
Front de gauche était tête de liste sur
cette liste commune vous partiriez avec
eux pourquoi pas pour l'instant on n est
pas à parler de personne on en est à
parler de projet ce qu'on souhaite nous
c'est pouvoir partager des propositions
pour l'avenir on sait qu'on sera pas
forcément d'accord surtout à l'échelle
de l'aglomération avec avec nos
partenaires sur ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent nous ce qu'on veut c'est
réussir à partager des propositions pour
pour l'avenir ce qu'attendent les
inontins c'est ça ils attendent pas
forcément des listes divisées et 10
listes au premier tour avec des
candidats qui finalement seront
inaudibles parce qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
à faire valoir leur propre position donc
ce sera votre défi réussir à vous mettre
déjà d'accord pour proposer une liste
comm prier défi après ça ne dépendra pas
forcément que de nous alors l'opposition
a-t-elle eu une chance à montinil
Bretonneux c'est notre question du jour
voici quelques réponses de des lecteurs
potentiels sur votre commune pas de
chance je crois pas sur mon je pense que
généralement c'est toujours la même
politique je pense qu'il y a plus de
gauchiste que de gens de droite ici
l'opposition aura des chances
effectivement ça fait déjà plusieurs
années qu'il est sur la commune donc je
pense que les gens sont assez contents
donc je pense que il va rester
aussi la prochaine fois non je pense
qu'il quand même bien ancré parce que ça
fait un moment qu'il est ici puis il a
fait des choses bien pour la ville donc
pour moi non parce que je pense que les
gens sont satisfaits oui oui une
alternance pour pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas je pense que voilà ça serait ça ça
serait ça serait une bonne chose aussi
bon moi je je suis pas contre la
politique actuelle mais il y a toujours
des petites modifications à faire al
pourquoi pas un changement même si pour
l'instant on s'entend plutôt bien avec
le maire actuellement en place et puis
le problème c'est le déficit de
notoriété aussi va falloir y travailler
c'est ça tout à fait on va y travailler
alors pourquoi pas un changement on ne
va pas faire le grand soir ici à Montini
quand on parle de quand on parle de
changement et de et d'une autre vision
de de Montini on on va pas forcément
remettre en cause tout ce qui a été le
fondement de la ville nouvelle je
rappelle que la la la ville nouvelle
c'est c'est d'abord faite sur
l'agglomération sur l'idée que un
certain nombre de communes se regroupent
7 aujourd'hui euh pour un projet commun
et la plupart des équipements sont
aujourd'hui des équipements
communautaires euh on a certaines
dissensions avec l'agglomération ici à
Montini on n'est pas certain que ce soit
une bonne chose pour pour notre
territoire de pas réussir à à s'accorder
sur des questions culturelles par
exemple que l'agglomération et ses
équipements d'un côté la ville et ses
équipements de l'autre euh chacun sa
politique on n'est pas certain que ce
soit forcément le le seul avenir
possible euh il est certain que il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
depuis depuis 30 40 ans sur sur la ville
nouvelle beaucoup par l'agglomération un
certain nombre aussi
par pas forcément le maire sortant mais
en tout cas son auguste
prédécesseur Nicolas Abou aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est pas face à Nicolas Abou
qu'on est c'est face à Michel logier
c'est c'est une nouvelle équipe mais qui
s'est pas vraiment renouvelé ce qu'on
croit c'est que oui on peut faire mieux
on peut rajeunir on peut Nouvé on peut
on peut proposer un avenir alors si on
regarde justement la liste
éventuellement qui sera proposée par
Michel logier si les candidatures
investitures se se se deviennent plus ou
moins officiel dans les prochains mois
il y a un personnage dont une personne
dont on a beaucoup parlé un personnage
même c'est Mathieu Colombani qui mène le
parti chrétiendémocrate qu'on retrouve
également sur la liste jusqu'à présent
il siège dans la majorité et c'est lui
qui s'est illustré ces ces derniers mois
en tant que l'une des des figures de
prou de de défense contre ce mariage
pour tous c'est une personnalité que
vous n'appréciez pas forcément je vous
fais cette remarque parce que sur vos
comptes officiels de Twitter et autres
vous ciblez en général vos attaques sur
lui j'attaque pas une personnalité
j'attaque une politique je vais même
vous faire une confidence j'ai habité
pendant 2 ans avec quelqu'un qui partage
dans une certaine mesure les idées de de
Monsieur Colombani eu j'ai j'ai aucun
aucune question avec cette personnalité
que je ne connais pas j'ai l'impression
que c'est quelqu'un qui est très
militant ce que je respecte euh
maintenant non sur les idées politiques
je pense que on est on est à l'extrême
opposé de des idées de de Monsieur
Colombani pour nous la vie en société
c'est tolérance c'est ouverture c'est
progrès social c'est c'est progrès des
droits et en cela je suis pas sûr qu'on
retrouve monsieur Colombani à tous les
niveaux alors il se dit aussi que
Monsieur Colombani pourrait ne pas être
sur la liste de Michel logier ça
pourrait peut-être laisser supposer
qu'il y aurait une liste complémentaire
plus une liste Front national aussi qui
se dessine puisque le Front national n'a
pas caché ses ses envies de de se lancer
sur cette commune de Montini il y a
beaucoup de candidats sur la ville de
Montini cette année ça va changer 2008
on va laisser nos adversaires faire
enfin faire les leurs leurs petits
arrangements euh ce qui semblerait c'est
que Michel logier soit le candidat de
l'UMP il a été le candidat du centre la
dernière fois Nicolas Abou était le
candidat du centre donc on n'est pas
exactement dans la même
configuration monsieur Colombani n'est
pas exactement sur la même ligne que un
certain nombre de centristes ou centre
droit non plus euh je sais pas si le
Front national monsieur Colombani
monsieur logier seront tous sur la même
liste sur deux listes sur trois listes
et j'ai presque envie de dire que ça
m'intéresse pas moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est qu'on puisse s'entendre sur un
projet de gauche avec nos nos
partenaires potentiels d'Europe Écologie
comment sétablir le programme d'ailleurs
dans les prochaines semaines prochains
mois quel est le calendri on commence à
travailler on commence à travailler on a
on a beaucoup de propositions beaucoup
d'idées on commence à en tester
quelques-unes auprès des inimontins EU
on sait que nos partenaires sont aussi
en train de travailler de leur de leur
côté euh prochainement je l'espère on va
pouvoir réunir toutes ces bonnes idéeslà
euh allit continuer de tester ses idées
puisqueencore une fois il s'agit pas de
faire un programme dans une dans une
chambre dans un coin mais de travailler
avec les inmtains et puis on élaborera
définitivement un programme plus tard
dans l'année je vais vous poser une
dernière question parce que votre nom
n'est pas forcément inconnu à ceux qui
suivent un petit peu aussi l'actualité
vous êtes le fils d'Henry Gasque ancien
instituteur première victime du forcené
Jean-Pierre rou du Rafour qui a battu
quatre personnes on a blessé SEP autres
c'était à tour en 2001 donc ça remonte à
une bonne dizaine d'années il a été
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité a sorti d'une mesure de
sûreté de 22 an est-ce que c'est cet
élément très marquant dans votre
parcours personnel a aussi joué dans
votre engagement en politique sans faire
de raccourci est-ce que ça construit
aussi une personnalité forcément c'est
pas complètement
impossible je pense que la personnalité
de mon père et de ma mère d'ailleurs m'a
construit davantage encore que cette
épreuve là de cette épreuve je tire
peut-être une certaine force de de
conviction et puis cette idée que ce
qu'on peut pas faire aujourd'hui on peut
pas forcément le faire demain voilà
merci Vivien Gasque donc candidat PS
àtini le Bretonneux et puisque on parle
de politique sachez que le Front de
gauche vient de créer aussi un collectif
sur le canton de saint-cer l'école
première réunion publique afin de
préparer les municipales selon les
organisateurs ce sera le 26 juin à 20h30
dans la salle des fêtes de la commune
merci une fois de plus à vous on vous
retrouvera prochainement sur ce plateau
pour débattre une fois que les listes
seront bien arrêté dans l'ensemble des
communes